This is the pH scale we’d looked at in the
first part of the video:
The acidic nature increases as we move towards
the left, and the basic nature
increases as we move towards the right. Higher
the concentration of H plus ions,
lower will be the pH. And lower concentration
of H plus ions will imply higher pH
value.
The pH scale basically tells us the strength
of an acid or a base! The ‘p’ in pH
stands for potenz which means ‘power’
or ‘potential’ in german. We can
understand it as the power of H plus ions.
More the number of H plus ions, more
acidic it’ll be.
Usually, a paper impregnated with the universal
indicator is used to measure the
pH. Before we understand what a universal
indicator is, we need to have a basic
idea of what indicators are!
Substances which show the acidic or basic
behavior of other substances, by
changing in some way, are known as indicators.
These are some of the common types of indicators:
Natural, Olfactory, Synthetic, Universal
As the name suggests, indicators obtained
from natural sources are called natural
indicators. Litmus and turmeric are examples
of natural indicators. Litmus is
obtained from lichens. If you remember, an
acid turns blue litmus paper red and a
base turns red litmus paper blue!
Substances which change their SMELL when mixed
with acid or base are
referred to as olfactory indicators. Onion
and vanilla are examples of
olfactory indicators. Paste or juice of onion
loses its smell when added with
base. It does not change its smell with acid.
And the smell of vanilla vanishes
with base, but its smell does not vanish with
an acid. Do you know why
they’re used? They are used to ensure the
participation of visually impaired
students in the laboratory. Interesting isn’t
it?
What are Synthetic Indicators?Indicators
that are SYNTHESIZED in the
laboratory are known as synthetic indicators.
Phenolphthalein and methyl
orange are two examples of synthetic indicators.
Phenolphthalein is a
colorless liquid and remains colorless with
acid, but turns pink with a base.
Methyl orange is originally orange in color
and turns red with acid and yellow
with base.
If you noticed, the following indicators only
tell us the acidic or basic
character of a solution! But it doesn’t
tell us the STRENGTH of the acid or
base! That’s what brings us to the universal
indicator!
A universal indicator shows different colors
over the range of pH values from
1 to 14 for a given solution. And it is available
in the form of strips as well as
solutions. This is how the color matching
chart looks!
pH values from zero to six show acidic nature.
And pH values from eight to
fourteen show basic behavior. And a pH of
seven shows that it’s purely
neutral!
Let’s see what colors some of the most common
substances result in!
Do you know the acid that forms in our stomach?
Yes gastric acid! It has a pH
of about one point two. And that tells us
how acidic it is!
Lemon juice has a pH of around 2.2 to 2.4.
What about coffee? It has pH of
about 5. It’s weakly acidic!
Distilled water has a pH of 7. Totally neutral.
And human blood has a pH of
about 7.3 to 7.5.
Baking soda has a pH of around 8.3 which tells
us that its weakly alkali.
Household ammonia has a pH of around 12. Yes
very alkali! And a sodium
hydroxide solution has a pH of close to 14.
Extremely basic!
In the next video, we will understand the
importance of pH in everyday life!